getting into the world of prosthetics is
always something I really wanted to do I
grew up in the north England my father
was a manager of a local cinema I sort
of grew up with Star Wars and all the
science-fiction films and the 70s I
spent a lot of my childhood in my
bedroom covering myself in latex blood
and gore quite early on I realized I
wanted to make creatures and monsters
things that rubber basically so show
like Game of Thrones it's kind of like a
bucket list we will actually concept and
design the characters a lot of our crew
concentrate on painting a lot of guys
from a very sculptural sort of
background hairdressing definitely an
artistic process whatever the brief is
for the character we have to be
practical about things the artist is
going to be able to wear this stuff day
in day out it's not too heavy they're
gonna be able to breathe so to create a
prosthetic makeup and apply it to an
actor is very much team effort from your
sculpting your mold makers your people
who run silicon's people who prepare
onto pieces you could have a team of 10
15 20 people who could do the whole
process from start to finish and then
you could have two to five people on the
day actually gluing these pieces on so
it's definitely a team effort and it's
something I couldn't be responsible for
myself
the build of a character would usually
start with a live cast basically making
a mold of the actors head which we can
then make duplicate heads out of who
then sculpt the makeups and all the
forms in a modeling clay all over the
head and then we would make molds of the
modeling clay basically on the former's
of their face once we have our mold the
majority of our appliances are made out
of silicon rubber which can be glued to
the face and then the edges can be blend
blended away you might be applying hair
which usually punched in with a very
fine needle all individually and then we
need to do duplicate sets of prosthetic
appliances for every single day that the
character films it's all quite a
painstaking process really from start to
finish we usually say an average kind of
build time is about four weeks for a
prosthetic character
our daily process in the prosthetics
department would usually have like 2-3
a.m. calls get our artists in the chair
the process of gluing them into their
prosthetics is usually about two to
three hours and the guys would then
travel to hair the moment we start with
these guys to the moment they step onto
set it could be five or six hours and
then we would have a filming day of say
about eight nine ten hours following the
artists around all day is prodding them
and maintaining the makeup then at the
end of the day and then have the D
rigging process which is involves us
basically peeling the prosthetics off
with a brush and mineral oils and so you
can't just rip these things off because
if we take a layer of the skin with it
with it and then we would usually be the
last day at the end of the day what
makes Game of Thrones so special I don't
think I've ever worked on a project
that's got such a varied amount of
prosthetics and have such a variety of
things to make that it's very rare
you'll be on a project and you'll be
decapitating somebody the wrong week and
then you'll be doing a full-body
prosthetic the next week but the most
enjoyable memories is probably the end
of hardhome last year was very cold wet
muddy smokes snow we had it all going on
we were covering them in loads of rubber
each day at times it felt like
pandemonium and then you just look
across and have a look at the monitor
and it was so cleverly choreographed and
orchestrated he couldn't believe what he
was seeing on film was what was right
next to you the feeling of achievement
was incredible I think that's probably
one of the best memories I'll take home
so far from Game of Thrones
YouTube's new Game of Thrones footage
let's break it down all kinds of White
Walkers behind the scenes greyscale
let's go what this is is just intended
to highlight the amount of work that
goes into the practical effects you see
a little bit of the visual effects going
on in the background too
because some of these white Walker
scenes are happening against green
screen some of its blue screen but you
get the idea it takes an army of people
to make the show and they have some
season six footage and some season five
footage most of the season five stuff is
from hardhome but you also see a bit of
greyscale let's talk about the season
six stuff first so just careful for
spoilers for potential stuff that might
happen on the show some of this is going
to be speculation but because we saw it
in this teaser it's pretty straight
forward
so what we're looking at right here is
the new night's king that we saw in the
season six trailer this is not the
night's king from Hart home they may
have recast the actor they may explain
it some other way like there's some
other nights king it seems like there's
only one at any given time the way
George R Martin described him is that
the mythical night's king that used to
be the 13th Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch probably died a long time ago
so this night's king is someone new
re-examining some of the hardhome
footage you see that this version of the
night's king looks very different from
this version of the night's king this is
the actor they cast for that hardhome
episode so it looks like they probably
just recast them think of it as being
the same thing they did with the
mountain they recast him a couple times
so what's going on here they're teasing
big white Walker battle we know they're
white Walker unit was filming things
towards the end of their production run
like really really late in the year last
year so it seems like a big white Walker
battle is going to happen again just
somewhere different if they're not going
to go to the wall who are they going to
be fighting they already took down
hardhome so there's really only one big
option left
it looks like based on the roots that
they're prepping them in here they're
going to be fighting against bran in the
three-eyed Raven also in the air just
went out of the room what's going to
happen the three-eyed Raven and bran are
just two people even if they're really
powerful how are they going to defeat an
army just keep in mind that this might
be happening towards the end of season
six if there's only going to be eight
seasons then the producers really have
to start pulling aces out of their
sleeves and bran in the three-eyed Raven
are really two of those aces now I don't
know if the three-eyed Raven will end up
making it
the end of the series we might wind up
with a situation where he just kind of
transfers his responsibilities to brand
he might wind up being a Star Wars
situation with obi-wan Kenobi and Luke
where the three-eyed Raven sacrifices
himself in some big battle with the
White Walkers were really an uncharted
territory but it seems like the
three-eyed Ravens job right now is to
just prepare brand for the new role that
he's going to take as a green seer he's
meant to replace them meaning that the
three-eyed Raven was probably never
meant to be around indefinitely but that
is firmly in speculation territory all
we really know is that there's going to
be a big bad ass white Walker battle
just like hardhome the weird thing to me
is who these white walkers going to be
fighting like how old brand in the
three-eyed Raven manifests a defense
against this many people so let me know
in the comments just based on this
footage do you think the white walkers
are going to go after the three-eyed
Raven and bran and what do you think is
going to happen during that battle one
of my other favorite quotes from this
video is that they have to be really
careful with the way they take these
prosthetics off so imagine like at the
end of this big battle they get done
filming they call cut and they say okay
we're done and someone just rips their
white Walker makeup off they would
actually wind up dead because they'd be
ripping half of their skin off they
would totally bleed out it'd be crazy
they're a whole lot of reasons why Game
of Thrones win so many wars that the
really the conversation this year was
about how they won a record number of
Emmys for the previous season for season
5 not only do they dominate the more
traditional categories like acting
directing screenwriting but they also
dominate the technical award categories
which is what they do for people do
amazing costumes visual effects amazing
set design things like that can you even
imagine the warehouse where they keep
all this stuff that they create some of
it probably doesn't last and some of it
probably gets reused in successive
seasons but that's why I feel like
they're really going to push for a
spin-off series because they've already
honed the craft of making these episodes
making these prosthetics they have this
amazing award-winning team I think HBO
is going to do everything in its power
to try and keep them together even if
Dan and Dave don't want to do a spin-off
series themselves it's really a question
of finding the right producers in the
right writers because George are Martin
said that when they first bought the
rights to do Game of Thrones HBO was
like we want to see Game of Thrones on
our network for 10 years in Martin was
like yeah that Sal
great I would love to have ten years of
Game of Thrones but because dan and Dave
have only been talking about eight
seasons that would mean that they would
have to do a spinoff but there hasn't
really been any meaningful conversation
about that in the last year or so
they're mostly focused on promoting the
main series but don't worry even after
this season we still have two more years
so giveaway time congratulations to this
week's DVD giveaway winner
Cameron ward just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
is just on the about page so I can get
your contact info what's going to happen
is I'll post a new bonus video on Sunday
that's when the new round of the
giveaway will start if those that are
asking there's a whole bunch of
daredevil that I still need to get
through don't worry that will happen
through the course of this week there's
just a whole bunch of stuff that came
back so you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates on when videos are
coming those links are at the bottom of
the description if you guys haven't seen
it the actor who played Stannis
Baratheon was saying some funny things
you can click here to learn all about
that and you can click here for the red
band trailer again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you